The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome back.
We're going to be looking at
problem number 11 in the fall
2009 final exam.
This is one of those problems on
the exam that kind of tests
a whole bunch of other
stuff we couldn't get
into one big question.
So it's looking at a bunch
of different areas.
But the main themes are going
to be bonding and reaction
rates and half lives.
So the things I think you need
to know, the W I N list as I
usually call it, you
need to understand
reaction rate orders.
What they mean, how they
apply to reactions.
What a half life is and
how you use that.
And the third thing is melting
points and how they are
related to intermolecular forces
and how intermolecular
forces affect melting points.
So review these three things and
once you've got them under
your belt then let's attempt
the problem.
So let's start the problem.
The first part is asking us to
determine the half life for a
particular reaction.
So there's two places
you could start.
We saw both answers.
You could start with the
definition of half life.
If you've got it down on your
equation sheet, you could just
say, well I know this is the
equation which is the natural
log of the starting
concentration--
c naught--
divided by the current
concentration that you're
looking at-- c--
equals kt, where t is time and
k is your constant for k.
Or your reaction
rate constant.
Or-- and this is the place
that I would recommend
starting because it's
universally useful to use for
doing kinetics problems
and also for
doing half life decays--
you start with your
rate equation.
This is a very general rate
equation, which I'm going to
show you how it can be
transformed to solve this very
simple problem.
We're told here that we're
looking at the half life of a
particular reagent,
it's not listed.
And we're also told
that it falls by
factor of 11 in 11 minutes.
Because we're looking at one
material, we don't need two
different items. So we're
just going to look at a.
Let's forget about b.
There's no b.
OK, we're just looking at
how a changes over time.
We're also told that
it's first order.
So we're given this information
in the problem.
First order means that you
have an n equal to 1.
So n equals 1, which turns this
equation into k times the
concentration of species a.
We also know that rate is
nothing more than the changing
concentration with respect
to the change in time.
So in calculus that
would be da / dt.
So looking at this now, we've
already got a differential
equation, which we can solve
and given certain boundary
conditions we can apply as
a naught as our starting
concentration, we can create
a new equation.
So the way we're going to do
this is we're going to do the
calculus-- which I'm not going
to do for you here--
it's very simply you're going
to find this equation.
This is all coming from the
very general rate equation
that we started with.
So there we are.
That's where we're at and you'll
notice if I bring this
a to the other side, I take
the natural log, I put a
negative sign in there, I return
back to my original
equation that I sort
of luckily--
or didn't luckily-- have
on my equation sheet.
So now we've got
this equation.
And now we can actually go ahead
and solve the first part
of the problem very easily.
So I'm going to move
over here.
We're going to start off.
We're going to say we're told
that in 11 minutes we have now
1/11 of the concentration
we originally had.
So let me write that
mathematically for you.
I'm going to write a naught
as my starting
concentration of a.
So in 11 minutes we're going to
have 1/11 a naught a naught
e to the negative k.
And that occurs in 11 minutes.
Just express the statement
mathematically.
We've can cancel out these a
naughts so they don't matter.
Which is good because we
don't know what it is
in the first place.
And now we can rearrange this
equation pretty simply.
We can just do it as,
solve for k, our
reaction rate constant.
That's going to be negative
1/11, natural log of 1/11.
That's k.
And now we have a value for k.
Now that we know the value
for k we can go back and
find the half life.
And half life is simply defined
very, very similar to
how we approached the problem
to begin with.
Half life is how long it takes
for the concentration to drop
from its original value to half
of that original value.
So let me write that now
in mathematical terms.
In this problem we know
k now but we don't
know the half life.
We don't know t 1/2.
I'm going to call it t 1/2 to
designate it and to mark it
differently than before.
Again we can cancel these off.
And now we can solve.
Because we know k.
So let's plug in everything.
We can reverse everything.
So let me do that for you.
We're going to have this.
Natural log of 1/2 being equal
to negative k, t to the 1/2.
And now we can solve for our t
1/2 because we know that k--
let's bring k to the
other side, and the
negative sign as well--
k is going to be negative
1/11 natural log 1/11.
We can then change natural log
1/2 into natural log 2.
That actually looks like our
original half life equation if
you had that on your
equation sheet.
So when you solve this out,
you're solving for t 1/2, t
1/2 the long and the short
of it is 3.18 minutes.
The main takeaway from this
problem is that you don't need
to have memorized any number
of equations to do it.
You can start from a very
general equation, which is the
rate equation, which we showed
in the beginning, and go from
there using logic and then just
mathematically represent
what the problem is telling you
to do in the first place.
So that's part A and that's the
majority of the points on
this problem.
Moving over, part B and C are
very quick, very short.
Just to check if you
know the facts.
Let's do them right now.
We're asking you--
we're going to do B 1
and B 2 together--
to tell us which one of
the compounds has a
higher boiling point.
And we give you two
different cases.
In each case there's
two compounds.
So number 1, you're given
silene and phosphene.
So the first thing you should
do is actually draw those
molecules out.
So that's what I did.
Silene looks like this.
And then phosphene--
put the bonds in there--
phosphene looks something
like this.
So now we have to sort of
identify which one of these
has a higher melting point.
Now in order to do that you need
to have reviewed and know
that melting point is related
to the intermolecular forces
between the between
the molecules.
The forces between the molecules
are dependent on
both their geometry and
their chemistry.
So knowing that, if something
has stronger intermolecular
bonds, it'll have a higher
melting point.
So let's take a look at
these two molecules.
Which one has stronger
intermolecular bonds?
We have in silene case, we have
van der Waals forces,
they're generally very weak.
We've got those tpo
for the phosphene.
But in phosphene we additionally
have a dipole.
We have partial--
we put maybe delta minus here
and delta plus here and here
on this side.
So our molecule is actually
polarized.
There's a plus region
and a minus region.
And because of that you have
much stronger intermolecular
forces between the phosphenes
then you do the silenes.
And because these have stronger
intermolecular
forces, this one has a
higher melting point.
The last part of the
problem, part 2.
We try to throw a little trick
in there with you.
We look at ammonia
and phosphene.
So now we're doing
NH3 and PH3.
And they actually both
look identical in
terms of their geometry.
So let me do that now.
It actually looks tetragonal
if you were to draw the
structure out.
There's ammonia and here's
our phosphene again.
You can tell they
look the same.
So I think you have to sort of
reason out which one has the
higher melting point, which is
the same thing as saying which
one has stronger intermolecular
forces.
A very common answer we got
was that the nitrogen is a
smaller atom, therefore
everything is held more
closely, therefore the
forces are stronger.
That's not really the answer
that is most dominant and it's
also not the answer we
were looking for.
The correct answer here is that
even though both of these
have the same--
probably very similar-- van der
Waals forces, they're both
polarized molecules, nitrogen
has hydrogen bonding.
So remember the hydrogen bonding
elements you should
probably know are fluorine,
oxygen, chlorine, nitrogen,
four of them.
So nitrogen will hydrogen bond,
which means that this
nitrogen will have a hydrogen
bond with some other ammonia
molecule over here.
This H might be bonded to
an N somewhere else.
And because there are additional
hydrogen bonding
force in the system, the
intermolecular forces are
stronger and more prevalent in
ammonia, which means that
ammonia will have a higher
boiling point, which is true.
The answer here is ammonia.
So all you have to take way
from this is that the
mechanical properties as well
as the melting and boiling
properties of a material are
very much governed by the
intermolecular forces that
exist in that particular
material, that the liquid
or the solid state.
And so in this case we're
looking at these compounds and
we've identified this one as
being a higher melting point
because it has a polarity
whereas this one doesn't.
And in this case where we try to
trick you up, we identified
that nitrogen has
this additional
hydrogen bonding force.
And that's all there is to it.